in other news tonight a drug deal turns  violent on the las vegas strip  right before a power outage causes chaos  at a major hotel and casino  8 news now reporter madison kimbrough  joins us live now near tropicana and las  vegas boulevard  with the latest on both of these  situations madison  currently there are two investigations  going on right across the street from  each other the first is a drug deal gone  wrong take a look at the video that we  shot earlier where you can see that  metro police  confirmed that two men in the casino  parking lot  as part of a drug deal met up but  something went wrong  and both men ended up shooting at each  other one man who was shot remained on  the lot  while the other man ran away we still  don't know the whereabouts of the  suspect that ran  off but the suspect that remained on the  lot of tropicana casino  has non-life-threatening injuries